yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
an international master here with the
Spanish flag I never know if the flags
are really correct but maybe he's got
dumb name in there yeah this is actually
the name unnai gabby's owed a goonie
yeah down so many m title players that
you never heard of okay we've got down
rue la paz Spanish opening everybody am
just playing d3 nowadays let's uh let's
try that yeah and this also gained some
popularity by now I don't do anything
fancy just c3 and continue developing
yep like I'm set up on the typical
formation um that you usually see in the
chigorin defense with Knight a5 and c5
the sugar in defense yeah sugar in
variation of the Royal it has no
relation to the knight c6 some line in
the Queens gambit declined
alright so I regrouped the night 2 2 g-3
which is a good thing it's a useful on
g3 but now I'm there are many things
that are possible white can try to
regroup further here to gain some play
on the King side or you can play deform
at at some point yeah come on I go
deform if I don't do that now deform
it's possible that black will actually
play d5 not sure if this would have been
great for black admittedly but I just
realized that I haven't played h3 so he
could have played Bishop g4 I'm not
saying that it is necessarily a great
for him but I didn't really recognize
this possibility
okay so black cam is certainly in quite
quite decent shape Bishop won't be seven
and all those pieces attack them the the
pawn on e4 so like some got some some
play but I have to spawn quite reliably
am protected so where do I go d 30 b 3
yeah d3m is small of a passive square
but it keeps this you for porn very
nicely protected okay i want to go here
and this still seems like the better on
and more active diagonal you know this
is also always one possible team to
simply m advanced e5 and try to solve
the whole of tension in the center yeah
the question is what happens if i take
on d5 you can probably take you 1 and
just take on d5 even with the bishop
yeah if i want to have anything i think
i should i need to play you five and now
back here
Nigel would have been interesting so I'm
kind of curious paw information I don't
really want to exchange them I try to
play Quincy form but he may be can play
Queen H form or this one interesting the
boom not sure if that's really am aha
Addis I really really didn't think of em
okay but what if I ignore all this and
play something like win h5 attacking f7
and attending e-cigs and stuff like that
isn't this dangerous at least or Queens
for Queens e-force also quite
interesting
okay I'll just I just sec this if he
wants to take you should be five hour
thinking rock d7 my pic might be
interesting maybe he still should do
that Bishop f2 King edge one Bishop you
one yeah this one I was thinking that
this move on now what would be would be
nice ruka if a 25 is hanging so not
quite sure what what what is movers now
Bishop f4 I play rogue f7 and this is
really a big discovery threatening okay
here we go he wants to to block this
okay threatening the rock and
threatening am on f7 and there's also
this bb7 bishop that he needs to take
care of so now I can just check right
and grab grab this the b7 bishop he
doesn't really have a threat i think
just 99 Queen 24 right yeah Boop g2s I
discovered yeah this is an extra look
and here he really has no compensation
if it takes on h4 be too i take f5 and
if i take on f5 headsets it's just a
deadly pin yeah no no play it on laughs
it's a it's difficult to tell I mean it
was a bit of a bit of an out of the blue
thing but happening I don't know at this
point I don't know Quincy fight it's may
be interesting I don't know Queen g4 how
does the computer the computer just
wants to take everything okay so maybe
it was just just the total bluff it's
possible I thought I might have some
some sematech going but down that's
let's check briefly I didn't really
calculate I mean I was just gambling
he took here and this seems to be a
mistake not loved you to the move that
up late but something else okay and it's
let's check this nyame that couple of
things that are didn't really look at I
was thinking also e6 would be it would
be an idea just just this but black has
got the the very brutal reply f5 f5 is
really what the thing is if it takes
then there's roop t7 anti resins just
have a nice assess it's gone it's gone
just winning but he's got is called f5
and this is really brutal move his
heaven is just a check and nothing
nothing else if I take a can can play
something this and it's blocked so it
seems that this the sacrifice was just a
gamble and not correct
in the in the game he played this and
our Bishop f7 would have been good ok I
played rugby seven is also was also
winning ok and here Queen f7 and rugby
7s may be as strong along according to
come but well the rook is a look and I
still have an attack so it worked out
nicely but it wasn't really correct and
in this position here I I shouldn't like
windy for computer funny enough also has
Luke takes d4 as a possibility and so
let's check check this briefly rook
takes deform Queen takes root d1 back
and then queen age five though this is
interesting that got something here
they have got group d 6 and Bishop h6
and so on of course this is entirely
unrealistic that you would calculate to
this kind of things but it's funny
computer gives one slight edge okay or
maybe it is zero zero or something so it
seems to be playable not losing
instantly yeah thanks for watching this